moi je suis bien entendu tout ce qu'elle
dit la présidente assassine bon l'impact
des retraites sur le finance publique et
indéniable et puisque c'est même l'un
des premiers postes de nos dépenses
publiques et comme j'aurai l'occasion de
le rappeler en discussion générale c'est
très fort mais bien une réforme
budgétaire dont l'objectif est de
garantir la soutenabilité notre système
de retraite et assurer ainsi sa
pérennité elle a donc pas conséquence
toute sa place en loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale j'entends aussi
l'argument selon lequel cette procédure
ne laisserait pas le temps nécessaire au
débat je voudrais s'il y aller et que
nous avons ouvert avec le président
Larcher plus de 100 heures de débats
alors que nous passons en général 30
heures à examiner le PLFSS qui concerne
toutes les branches l'ensemble des
recettes et des dépenses de la sécurité
sociale
je rappelle que chaque année depuis 2019
à l'initiative de rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales pour
l'assurance vieillesse le Sénat a
examiné cette réforme et a pu en
débattre alors le Conseil
constitutionnel sera certainement saisi
en effet il se lancera conformément à sa
mission j'entends bien la présidente
assassy qui voudrait qu'on anticipe ce
que pourrait être une décision du
Conseil constitutionnel nous ne sommes
pas sur cette ligne et j'invite donc le
Sénat à se prononcer contre cette motion
merci
[Musique]